[Applaudissements]
ce dont je vais vous parler ce soir ce
sont les entreprises qui ont décidé de
poursuivre la valeur sociale d'abord et
de jouir des profits ensuite comme une
conséquence parce que ces entreprises
ont décidé de se concentrer sur les
manques de leurs écosystèmes leurs
clients leurs fournisseurs et
communautés locales
nous avons appelé les interviews
altruiste du mot latin alter l'autre
pour bien comprendre la nature
révolutionnaire de cette approche je
vous invite de revenir 50 ans en arrière
le voir ce qu'ils s'autorisent ont fait
par rapport à la valeur sociale
milton friedman il ya cinquante ans
exactement écrit cet article dans lequel
il a dit que la seule responsabilité de
l'entreprise et de maximiser les profits
il n'était pas content nos valeurs
sociales mais il disait que les
propriétaires eux sont libres d'y
contribuer une fois que les entreprises
ont tout fait pour maximiser les profits
pourtant si notre approche qui serait
pendu à partir des années 80 la rse une
approche d'ailleurs qui est obligatoire
d'un certain nombre de pays en france à
partir de 500 personnes elle a fait
beaucoup de contributions positives mais
il a aussi sujet à quelques critiques
la principale étant que la poursuite de
la valeur sociale et la valeur
environnementale est subordonnée à la
recherche du profit et si les
entreprises poursuivent et la valeur
sociale et des profits en même temps
c'est ce qu'a proposé john elkington
dans les années 90 un auteur et
consultant britannique
avec cette approche de ce triple bottom
line qui était très populaire dans des
milliers d'entreprises qui a inspiré
d'ailleurs aussi la proche de
certification by corp est un tout petit
peu plus tard benefit corporation ce qui
a donné l'entreprise en mission en
france
toutes ces approches l'un part d'une
volonté très louable pour suivre un
appoint la valeur sociale
environnementale et les profits est ce
réaliste
est ce réaliste de courir plusieurs
lièvres à la fois
peut-on à la fois maximiser les profits
et la valeur sociale peut-on en même
temps maximiser le nombre d'objets que
vous achetez et votre compte en banque
c'est impossible par conséquent la
raison principale de ces approches alain
de triple bottom line bicorps l'état
prisa mission c'est pas que elles ne
vont pas assez loin mais que si
j'approuve ne se rapprochent ne peuvent
pas le faire pour que l'on puisse
contribuer les services puisqu'on devait
davantage la valeur sociale que toutes
ces approches
il faut arrêter de courir plusieurs
lièvres à la fois
milton friedman leur ai dit oui il est
parfaitement d'accord il faut poursuivre
les lièvres des profits les dirigeants
d'entreprises que nous avons rencontrés
ont fait un choix inverse ils ont décidé
de poursuivre un seul lièvre mais celui
de la valeur sociale qu'est ce que nous
avons découvert avec mon co auteur
laurent marc bacci les entreprises elles
truies ce sont des entreprises qui ont
décidé de se mettre aux
service de tous les membres de leur
écosystème et clients les fournisseurs
les communautés locales de le faire à
travers toutes les activités de leur
coeur de métier et de le faire de
manière inconditionnelle après tu vas me
poser la question et les profits des
entreprises altruiste et bien allons-y
on va regarder une de ces entreprises
qui est la laiterie de saint denis de
l'hôtel qui se trouve dans le loiret une
des plus grandes actrices françaises
vous connaissez certainement la marque
c'est qui le patron dont lsdh était à
l'origine est produit toujours site mac
a permis de sauver de la faillite 80
producteurs du libre et soins mais je
raconte est une autre histoire d'une
autre marque
ils s'appellent les 30 fermes quant au
vote
si vous tournez un tout petit peu vous
voyez ici une trentaine de familles
s'oriente heureuse et pourtant
en 2010 ils n'étaient pas ceux rien du
tout ces trente producteurs de cantal
l'aveyron du lot éloigné de des
industries laitières et donc il était à
l'abandon ces industries parce que
c'était trop heureux de récolter le
relais et un dernier recours sont partis
voir emmanuel vasseneix qui est le
président de l'ess d'acheter une idée de
produire une marque spécifiquement à
partir de lait de ses producteurs et de
lavande euros prix fixe et avec la marge
garantie pour le producteur et
l'industriel casino a accepté c'est
fermiers été sauvé de la faillite
et le résultat est d'un mini lsdh
d'ailleurs est né après la guerre
déjà par le souci de sauver
et producteurs du lait cette fois-ci de
centre de france dont on ne voulait pas
du lait parce qu'encore une fois trop
éloignés des centres de de production et
aujourd'hui ils continuent d'agir pour
le bien des agriculteurs partout en
france y compris pendant le coït vous
aime dire est ce que cette entreprise
est profitable
les entreprises altruiste apprécié les
profits mais ils font un pari ces deux
d'abord agir pour l'un valeurs sociales
et espérer que les profits vont arriver
comme une conséquence pour ces
entreprises le profit c'est un peu comme
de l'eau on ne vit pas pour boire le
maximum de lots possibles
on en a besoin de l'eau pour vivre bien
et longtemps
c'est pareil pour ces intervenants qui
ont besoin des profits pour pérenniser
leur entreprise pour créer de la valeur
sociale
d'ailleurs c'est du bon sens quand vous
m'entendez de dire ça ce bon sens est
d'ailleurs à l'origine de la plupart
d'entreprises
prenez cette question pourquoi on crée
des interprètes pourquoi nous apprenons
créé les entreprises en réponse à vos
jouets aux questions champions pour
faire des profits
réponse b pour la liberté d'action et la
réalisation de soi je vous demande pas
de pronoms de prononcer mais je vous
dise qu'on avance et milton friedman lui
l'aurait dit prônant pour faire des
profits
et pourtant on peut soumettre sans cette
hypothèse à un test ce qu'ils ont fait
deux chercheurs de princeton et de
stanford qui ont contacté 65000
personnes demandant s'ils sont en train
de créer leur entreprise ils ont
identifié 830 quitter un train d'être
des créateurs d'entreprise ils ont
soumis à un test pour voir quelles sont
leurs motivations de créer leur
entreprise est là
surprise les interpréteurs créer leur
entreprise pour est un libre d'agir par
eux mêmes être leur propre patron en
quelque sorte et pour réaliser leur rêve
de offrir un produit ou un service qui
utile aux autres
utile à la société donc pour les
interpréteurs il s'agit non pas de créer
l'entreprise pour faire le maximum de
profit mais pau en avoir assez
évidemment mais pose justement
pérenniser cette jeune entreprise pour
pouvoir continuer à jouer de la liberté
d'action et de poursuivre ' les cette
étude là et là aussi une conséquence les
sens si vous voulez très important pour
les entreprises altruiste
les entreprises elles triste réalité ce
qu'elles font c'est de revenir vers le
pari originel qui t'aident à l'heure à
savoir faire tout pour les membres de
leur écosystème et d'espérer espérons
que les profits suivront alors est-ce
qu'il suivait ce qu'ils sont au rendez
vous juste envie de regarder cette belle
courbe par exemple de lys dh partir de
2007 quand cette entreprise la famille
vasseneix à regagner le contrôle
toujours dirigé lsdh une à partir de
2007 gagnés le contrôle et vous voyez
les résultats en termes de chiffre
d'affaires de cette croissance toujours
profitable d'ailleurs dans cette
entreprise là on partage 20 % des
profits avec des salariés avant 2007
cette démarche était d'ailleurs reconnu
par un très grand nombre de prix est
compris
ce dernier prix voici donc le pari des
entreprises
altruiste arrêté de poursuivre les
profits et de se consacrer un
conditionnement
pour prendre soin des membres de leur
écosystème et espérer que cet écosystème
prendre un soin d'eux c'est ce que nous
avons vous découvrir avec mon co auteur
laurent marbach et pendant cinq ans un
allant d'un plusieurs dizaines
d'entreprises dont elle est idéale celle
unique
un exemple sur trois continents de tous
secteurs du type de taille
alors en ce moment peut-être ce que vous
pensez c'est que moi et mon co auteur en
apprenant le fut mais quelque chose
le clown est parti sur trois continents
de rencontrer quelques dizaine de
patrons qui eux aussi ont fumé quelque
chose et que en réalité peut-être notre
société ne s'attend pas du tout de ça de
nos entreprises
permettez moi de vous donner juste un
chiffre sur ses attentes croissantes
dans nos sociétés vis-à-vis des
entreprises
millennial je vois qu'il ya ici dans la
salle ceux qui sont nés entre 1984 et
2000 qui représente 50 % de salariés en
france
aujourd'hui que dans dix ans vont
représenter 75 % de salariés
quel pourcentage de ces mélanges crois
qu'un succès de l'entreprise ne doit pas
être mesurer uniquement un terme
financier allez-y dites-moi quelques-uns
quel est le pourcentage
qu'est ce que vous en pensez 70 encore
une proposition ok bon vous êtes vous
n'êtes pas loin bon 87%
vous voulez voter les meilleurs parmi
eux voulait les garder et j'ai des
statistiques de ce type non seulement
par rapport à des salariés mais aussi
par rapport à des consommateurs public
en général et rendez vous compte des
investisseurs donc
hier les entreprises pouvaient
parfaitement ignoré les attentes des
salariés des consommateurs de public en
général des investisseurs aujourd'hui ça
paraît impossible
c'est juste pour vous dire que c'est pas
seulement - qui fument mais que tout le
monde fume vous en l'occurrence en
partie aussi dernière points quel est le
secret de ces entreprises qui leur a
permis de transformer leurs activités de
coeur de métier est justement de gagner
ce pari
c'est la confiance
c'est la confiance qui leur a permis
d'agir vis-à-vis des membres écosystème
sans condition et sans protection
comment les entreprises classiques
construisit leurs rapports avec les
membres de leur écosystème et le fond
sous la protection d contraints et ce
conditions de retour sur investissement
on appelle ça comment les transactions
économiques les entreprises
altruiste ont décidé de conduire leurs
rapports avec clément de l'holocauste m
en tant que relation authentique comme
si vous faisiez avec vos amis si vous
invitez un ami pour passer un week end
chez vous vous ne dites pas tu es un ami
tant que tu me coûte pas trop cher
autant que j'ai un retour sur
investissement sur toi
concrètement si votre client tarde à
payer plutôt que d'envoyer lettre
recommandée vous avez vos à guérir de
ses difficultés peut-être d'ailleurs il
apparaît sur votre facture
ça arrive vous qui l'êtes difficultés de
trésorerie dans quels cas peut-être vous
pouvez échelonner le paiement la même
avec le fournisseur qui a des problèmes
vous allez peut-être chercher comment
l'idée plutôt que le remplacement et les
profits en réalité si vous construisez
les rapports avec les bancs d'auto votre
écosystème et vous faites tout pour
prendre soin d'eux à cet écosystème
elle prendra pas conscience de soi un
nouveau peut-être certains parmi vous
vous le faites déjà au sein de vos
entreprises
sans le savoir mais si vous prenez
pleinement conscience et vous appliquer
complètement cette hausse de fille de
l'entreprise vous pouvez vraiment rendre
le monde meilleur
et grâce à cela rendre votre entreprise
prospère
merci
[Applaudissements]